[Musique]
madame from un bon jour on m'a amenée à
la cathédrale marie reine du monde entre
ont d'abord vous voulez nous faire
découvrir quelqu'un d'extraordinaire oui
c'est vrai si le mot week c'est
quelqu'un que j'admire beaucoup
pourquoi parce que d'abord si le prêt de
la paroisse où j'ai été élevé puis quand
mon père a eu la maladie de l'alzheimer
père couturier terrain pour nous aider
nous a donné aux bénévoles nous vraiment
guider dans soho ça fait toute la
différence pour ma mère moi et
aujourd'hui je veux lui dire merci et je
les admire père couturier parce que il
l'a une journée de congé par semaine
qu'ils consacrent à chausser les sans
abri pense que vous l'avez suivi dans
son parcours il ramasse les vieux
souliers que dont les gens ne veulent
plus ils les répare il fait tout avec
sous entendre sa voix dans l'aube où il
voulait souligner beaucoup des
espadrilles cette semaine où trouver ces
admirables
oui si le mot merci beaucoup aux bonnes
sont maintenant bravo prendra merci
beaucoup
jean pierre couturier bonjour bonjour
les airs et vouloir vous appelle le
petit père
oui ça va arriver sur un chaque moment
donné où des gens m'ont remis des
chaussures puis hâte de trouver sur
papier alors dit ok on va appeler ça le
petit père on m'a dit tellement de
belles choses sur vous
d'abord cette volonté d'aider ceux qui
en ont besoin et les sans abri de les
chausser
ouais si vous ça vous est arrivé comment
cette idée c'est arrivé j'étais vigueur
à l'époque ici la cathédrale il ya des
dames qui sont venus me voir pour me
dire que notre jean paul là qu'on voyait
tous les jours qu'on m'a fait ressentir
pas très bon on n'a jamais amené au
sujet des faits se déchausser et là j'ai
vu la gangrène qui étaient là et c'est
comme ça que tout a commencé
on est donc cathédrale
marie-reine-du-monde j'étais installé en
bord c'est ça après quelques âmes et
ailleurs j'ai finalement demandé de
mettre ici au centre-ville où tout se
passe montrez-moi sont bien sûr avec
l'essai
à
elle avait que moi pour ici ici c'est
aussi le bois ça sert de dépôt de fait
que nombreuses églises ferme
et puis c'est un peu le dépôt de ces des
costumes que les prêtres porte encore
beau non non non
l'honneur dans votre antre à la sete
cidades ailier montrez-moi sur votre
équipement bon ça ici parce que c'est
j'écoute des ordres et comme il n'ya pas
de pied qui attendent après les
chaussures que je dois réparer j'y vais
au rythme qui se veut votre matière
première ce sont des cyniques des gens
laissent dans des magasins quand il
s'achète de nouveau subi et les parents
et vous souvent vous arrivez en refaire
des souliers correct absolument
complètement corps est d'ailleurs
souvent ça ne manque pas grand chose
oui il ya des questions de mode qui vont
peut-être justifier l'abandon d'une
paire de chaussures
il ya aussi le fait que vous savez vous
connaissez peut-être la blague qui veut
que quelqu'un change de voiture par le
cendrier plein vous pouvez les
transposer à caen les deux là c'est son
cas c'est un
il y en a qui vont changer de chaussures
mais tant mieux dans certains camps il
ya tant mieux qu'il ya des gens comme
vous pour les récupère les récurrences
épouvantable qu'on les jette mais c'est
quand même technique ce métier que vous
avez appris ensuite par vous m avez
absolument ressembler sur les changes et
l'on connaît combier vous pouvez en
faire comme ça et en distribuer jusqu'à
lequel aurait peut-être 12 boîtes qui
peuvent contenir jusqu'à une quinzaine
vingtaine de paires par semaine bah oui
oui c'est beaucoup 200 par semaine ça
donne ça va à peu près vous êtes une
usine à vous tout seul ouais j'aurais
besoin des petits lutins par exemple
puisque vous croiser des gens dans la
rue qui porte les souliers que vous avez
réparer des fois ça vous arrive des fois
pour
probablement mais mais jamais à l'efo
c'est là que tu voulais savoir que c'est
utile oui ça vous amène quelque chose
bien sûr vous avez d'ailleurs au début
j'avais reçu une question semblable pour
que tu fais ça parce que je travaille
dans le domaine plutôt spirituel et puis
là où on ne voit pas les fruits parce
que ça ne nous appartient pas mais
j'avais besoin de quelque chose de
concret ça c'est pour la maison du père
cela est pas plaint encore mais je ne
reste pas de la remplir
le coût du matériel père oui couturier
qui fait pour ça c'est moi vous payez
pour jouer long j'ai eu des dons aussi
mais quand je ne pense à faire ben la
défense à faire les fous d'affaires
quand j'ai vraiment des grands besoins
vous une page facebook manche et des
petits pas et il ya des il ya des gens
attend qu'ils aient bon j'ai pas pour
vous et des champions oui tout ce qu'il
ya à faire
ah ben oui mais écoutez si vous êtes
fournir un bon je dis vous êtes dit
vraiment merci de nous avons fait
découvrir
on peut pas se douter qui a un père dans
le sous-sol de la cathédrale
marie-reine-du-monde qui répare des
souris et qui les donne aux sans abri en
trop où est entreposé on peut pas douter
tout ça c'est des originalités du
seigneur faut croire
[Musique]
oh